we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's an
interesting question from a caller take
a listen to this
david yes david from windsor ontario
thank you what will it take you ask
canada and the united states should
become one country if Canada's provinces
could be US states then the more you
know we have conservatives here too but
they're reasonable conservatives
relatively speaking and everything you
do in washington affects us directly so
it's in canadians best interest that
they be able to send elected
representatives to washington CD c-- 20
canadian senators even ten canadian
senators would change everything yes
they would you very much not gonna
happen so this is one of those ideas
that it's interesting to think about
sort of and i think that they're very
interesting sort of like under
foundational questions that are raised
but first and foremost I don't know
outside of Quebec whether Canadians have
any interest in being part of the US as
US states I don't think so
I can assure you that that in Quebec
there is no interest whatsoever in
becoming part of the United States
that's to begin with there is no way in
hell that the American right would have
any interest in any kind of merger
project with Canada like it's one of
those things where none of the parties
involved are going to be interested in
something like this well hey I mean we
have Alaska north and of course we have
the contiguous United States so we just
be completing that stretch of land I
think we have to make that case but you
can make the case and you will be
laughed at particularly by listen I know
a lot of people in Montreal and in
Quebec City and the idea of becoming
they don't even want to be part of
Canada lots of them right and the idea
of saying we will become a state of the
United States of it's just a nonce what
about if the US gives up its sovereignty
and becomes part of Canada so instead of
Canada becoming part of the United
States yeah you have the u.s. becoming
part of Canada maybe that would play
well you're conservative mine I suggest
talking to the tea party caucus about
that and seeing what it is or what are
they called they've merged into
something else now
like the freedom caucus or oh I love
that I don't even remember what they're
called now the extremists in Congress
caucus I'm sure they'll be all over
joining Canada we've got a great bonus
show for you today Donald Trump now
referring to stormy Daniels as horseface
on Twitter is this the new normal in
terms of how presidents talk about
things it sort of seems to be we will
talk about yet another vile and
disgusting act by our fellow New England
sports fans they really are horrible I
mean it is an embarrassment I'm as big a
fan of New England sports as anybody Pat
but the fans are vile every every week
we have a new story every month maybe
we'll also talk about the political
leanings of defense secretary Jim mattis
Mad Dog as Donald Trump likes to refer
to him on the bonus show
www.davidpakman.com/membership